president Trump hammered Democrats in
the second big speech of his week-long
vacation he told a rally in Manchester
New Hampshire last night that the
economy will tank if he is not reelected
Paula Reid is traveling to mr. Trump
who's now back at his New Jersey Golf
Club listen Paula New Hampshire is
important to all presidential candidates
but why in particular is it important to
this president a good morning again New
Hampshire gave President Trump his first
Republican primary victory in 2016 and
even though it's gone blue in every
election since 2004 the Trump campaign
thinks they can win New Hampshire in
2020 the 401ks
down the tubes everything's going to be
down the tubes so whether you love me or
hate me they got a vote for me President
Trump tried to project confidence about
the economy and his pitch to New
Hampshire voters a state he narrowly
lost to Hillary Clinton in 2016 and
recent polls show president Trump
trailing Democratic frontrunner Joe
Biden there by 10 points we should have
won New Hampshire that was taken away
the president defended his ongoing trade
war with China which economists say is
partly to blame for the market plunge
this week we are doing very well with
China despite the fact that they want to
have you
[Applause]
voters and attendants said their support
is unwavering
I think that he proved himself a lot in
the last three years the market the
stocks the jobs the economy and in his
first rally since mass shootings in Ohio
in Texas he stood firm on supporting gun
owners rights we will always uphold the
right to self-defense and we will always
uphold the Second Amendment we will in
recent days the president has said he
wants meaningful background checks but
continue to make this controversial
claim it's not the gun that pulls the
trigger it's the person holding former
Vice President Joe Biden also held an
event in New Hampshire last night to
capitalize on the president's visit his
team set up down the street from the
arena where the president had his rally
to talk to voters and recruit volunteers
Tony Paula Reed Forrest Paula thank you
very much